vigilant d'abord pour accompagner la
reprise vous savez que la reprise
progressive du trafic intérieur s'opère
depuis le 2 juin dernier depuis que la
règle des 100 km a été levée et il faut
à la fois être lucide sur la demande
la fréquentation de nombre de voyageurs
qui aujourd'hui montrent dans ces avions
qui reste très modeste de l'ordre de 20
à 25% et donc l'objectif c'est bien de
mettre pour 7
ce redémarrage progressif le bon nombre
d'avions la bonne la bonne offre
en face de la demande et c'est ce que
nous allons faire en lien avec les élus
la période de la réserve électorale
complique un peu ces échanges parfois
mais j'ai demandé notamment aux grands
opérateurs à air france d'avoir c'est
dialogue avec les garanties les links et
son indispensable à l'aménagement du
territoire
elles vont être préservés d'abord de
choses je dis que ces lignes était vital
pour l'aménagement du territoire et je
suis élu de limoges comme vous savez
nous avons des lignes sur un petit
service public
leur objectif n'est pas la rentabilité
bien de préserver l'attractivité de ces
territoires des lignes ou bien souvent
comme à aurillac le voyage par le train
en pas la route n'est pas une une
solution satisfaisante notamment pour le
tissu de pme et d'entreprises locales
donc il faut préserver
il faut préserver ses dunes
d'aménagement du territoire il faut
accompagner la reprise
avec clairvoyance avec lucidité parce
qu'aujourd'hui et vous le savez la
demande est relativement modeste
nous avons le mois d'août qui
traditionnellement est un mois peu
utilisé par les voyageurs et il faudra
pour septembre est particulièrement près
moi j'ai demandé à ce que l'ensemble des
opérateurs au lien avec les élus
produisent un plan avant le 1er juillet
de manière à ce que ce plan soit
exécutée au cours de l'été et après et
surtout cela s'inscrit bien sûr dans le
contexte d'une crise pour l'aéronautique
absolument sans précédent
hier le gouvernement a annoncé un plan
de soutien de 15 milliards d'euros axé
notamment sur la reconversion verte est
ce vraiment la réalité n'est pas une
nouvelle fois une perfusion pour un
secteur dont on sait qu'il va attendre
plusieurs années avant le retour à la
normale non d'abord c'est un plan de un
plan de résistance est un plan de
conquête un peu de résistance pour
amortir la crise
vous en connaissez les effets qui est
déjà terrible 95 % des vols qui ont été
supprimés alors ça reprend
progressivement une industrie qui pâtit
beaucoup de la crise le chiffre des abus
sont connus environ 40% de baisse
d'activité pendant deux ans donc une
crise durable
aucun plan de résistance ça c'est
l'ensemble des mesures que vous
connaissez parfaitement bien
l'activité partielle les prêts garantis
par l'état les fonds de consolidation et
puis un plan de conquête parce que le
vrai enjeu du transport aérien comme du
reste l'ensemble des transports et le
verdissement de façon de voir les choses
pour un secteur aussi polluant oui enfin
qui est beaucoup moins polluant que
qu'on le dise et 2,5 pour cent des gaz
des missions des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre mais ça reste
effectivement un des grands enjeux et
donc il ya deux façons de voir les
choses soient effectivement vous faites
un peu comme en 2008 concurrence avec de
vieux avions pour finalement volé pour
pas cher comme l'avait fait à l'époque
les américains pour reconstituer les
marges
soit vous investissez massivement ce que
nous faisons le choix politique que nous
faisons nous investissons massivement
avec un horizon assez clair un premier
avion régional hybride en 2027 et le
successeur vers deux a320 en 2035
c'est un défi considérable mais ce n'est
pas tout à fait hors de portée